désormais les accros du réseau internet
peuvent se procurer dans certains pays
étrangers des médicaments en principe
soumis à prescription médicale et
surtout des substances dont la
commercialisation est interdite quand il
ne s'agit pas purement et simplement de
drogue en quête françoise balle et
philippe deslandes
comment obtenir de la mélatonine un
produit en vente libre aux états unis
est interdite en france
c'est simple se connecter sur internet
et passer commande
on va moi de mettre le mode de paiement
visa mastercard ou american express visa
le pays dont il livre dans le monde
entier et on en voit edward a testé une
semaine après son pack est arrivé par
l'amour ces entreprises sont installées
à l'étranger en particulier aux états
unis
elle profite du réseau internet pour
vendre par correspondance toute une
gamme de produits on peut même acheter
des médicaments normalement délivrés sur
ordonnance médicaments qui en france
sont très surveillés par ce qu'il y a eu
des accidents mortels
ça peut être dangereux et c'est
extrêmement dommageable ya plus de suivi
pharmaceutique appui médical il ya des
personnes qui prennent des substances
qui n'ont pas été autorisés en france et
si elles n'ont pas été autorisées c'est
pour des raisons de santé publique
une vente directe ne présente aucun
intérêt pour le consommateur français
qui préfèrent être remboursés mais le
réseau permettent aussi d'accéder à des
substances illégales comme l'ecstasy
vous d'autres drogues et rien
aujourd'hui ne permet d'interdire ce
trafic
il joua pas comment on va pouvoir
aujourd'hui faire face à ce problème
autrement qu'en essayant de dégager une
démarche au niveau des états pour qu'ils
soient l'uniformisation soit une entente
au niveau douanière entre les différents
états de planet le médicament ou les
drogues sur internet sont en fait un
exemple de plus des problèmes posés par
le réseau comme le trafic d'armes ou de
cassettes pornographiques